how's everybody going good you guys all
here to see some JavaScript yeah so how
many guys do view angular react okay so
a lot more react got it I actually do a
lot of angular so a lot of these
examples I'm might reference some
angular stuff I don't know reacting to
you near as well and probably not near
enough to do the parallels so do you
guess we don't know any angular I
apologize but that's why it goes so I'm
Martine and today I'm going to talk to
you guys about web components and
specifically writing them without a
framework and the reason I kind of
thought about this talk and put this
talk together is because we just gone
through and written all our stuff run a
tan angularjs and it was the cool new
thing and then react kind of came along
and then angular came along and then you
came along and were like well we're
still we ended up moving everything to
angular but realistically we kind of
started thinking I would do a lot of
front-end mostly pretty much only
front-end and it was like well for the
next wave how would I get components to
actually transfer over to whatever the
next framework and whatever in it and
the next cool new thing is going to be
cuz there's bound to be one right it's
JavaScript we blink and there's a new
framework there's bound to be something
else coming down the pipe and so how
could I make it so that my components
would stay true across any of those
frameworks other safe a different team
who prefers to use reactor prefers to
use of you how could they go ahead and
make use of those components regardless
of whatever framework they want to use
so I started digging I'm like well all
of these frameworks do components at
some level I should be able to do them
in just JavaScript because browsers run
JavaScript it should be possible and it
actually is so that's what we're going
to talk about today we're going to look
at a decent amount of code so don't
worry at the very end there is a repo
out there on github and all that good
stuff I'll give you guys the URLs so
that you can check out the code for
yourselves if you want to and we're done
so but at the very core web component
what are they we talk about it a lot and
we know generally like we use them but
what are they and what they are are
basically reusable custom elements that
are encapsulated and that's the real big
thing about it it's encapsulated which
means I can take that element and just
plop it in anywhere and it's not going
to unless I wanted to interact with
what's around it so it's not because my
parent application has a set of styles
for example that it's going to affect
the styles inside of that component
I can encapsulate that and not make it
move so those customs elements that we
build the bait there's a JavaScript API
for them most of it and you uses the
shadow Dom and allows us to define what
those are going to be and then create
whatever elements we want and whatever
Styles we want whatever functionality we
want and go ahead and apply those so
we're going to look at how to do that
the last piece obviously is shadow DOM
should I mention a couple of times we'll
get and a little bit more about exactly
what that means I'll throw this graphic
back up but what it does is it allows
inside of our Dom to create another
piece another set of dot another Dom
inside of it that is encapsulated and
independent from the parent Dom so
there's a little bit of it of some fun
interactions there and it allows us to
control that from the functionality
inside of our component so there's
pieces and so to create a custom
component in vanilla JavaScript there's
kind of two pieces we can use there's
templates and slots templates are
generally we're not going to talk about
those much today but what those are is
they allow us to and I have those in the
wrong order
what templates do is they allow you to
take a piece have it in your HTML
somewhere it won't display until you
using JavaScript or basically tell it I
want to do X so they're great for an
element you might want to repeat
repeatedly but doesn't have a lot to go
with it and you're not going to be
referencing a whole bunch maybe in one
place I think a list or one-time use
case for a list it would be a good one
for that slots is the other piece slots
allow you to inject information into
that component and so that is for those
who know angular it's equivalent of
using ng content but that allows us to
from the parent application inject stuff
into our component and is one of the few
ways that we can actually interact with
our component because of the isolation
so I'd see a little bit of JavaScript
review because I know a lot of us play
with a lot of frameworks if you're in in
JavaScript you may have used those a lot
more often then maybe an angular but I
know as an angular dev it been a really
long time since that had to use any of
these functions so we're gonna go of
them really really quick just to kind of
refresh our memory and then we'll get
into what we're actually use them to
create our component
the first one is document create element
that's how we're going to actually
create that custom component and what
that allows us to do is take a tag name
and whatever and then we can start
forming our component with that we have
set attribute we're gonna use that in
order to create our IDs we're gonna use
that to add some classes any kind of
text attribute we might want to add
accessibility it wise if we want to add
Aria attributes those sorts of things
that's the tag we're going to be able to
use class lists that's how we're gonna
manipulate our CSS I'm gonna go and show
kind of two ways to handle the CSS with
our components but the add toggle remove
replace keeping in mind that I 11 may
bite you on this one most of what we're
going to talk about today works in
modern browsers ie 11 is not one of them
but if you're working with edge
especially edge chrome if you're working
with the latest version of Chrome
Firefox it'll work just fine perfectly
fine in the wild all of the examples
that I'm gonna show up are done in by
normal Chrome and I was even good I
didn't even take them in Safari and the
in canary I used the normal chrome
version so it will work in Chrome
without any kind of Babel or any kind of
finicky with it
appendchild that's what we're going to
use to kind of once we have all our
pieces inside of our component built
that's where we're going to use to help
put it together and actually built that
final element that's going to get
displayed so shadow dome that's kind of
the root of what we're going to use to
create that component and so we have a
normal Dom tree we're used to using it
it's got our elements and that's how we
can what using our javascript get
element by
to go do something or get by on my class
you know and get our elements and pieces
and it's kind of the route of the
document what the shadow Dom does is
inside that custom element we're going
to basically inject a second a second
Dom tree which is completely isolated
and going that's where our component is
going to live anything that happens
inside of that that shadow it's kind of
like a black box there's a very very few
things we can do to interact with them
we can pass information in and out but
you're not going to be able to do a
whole lot in terms of affecting what
happens in that box once the element is
created so - in order to do this little
demonstration a friend of mine jokingly
said you should bring back the blink tag
because we're all sad that the blink tag
went away
now I a lot of my other talks are about
accessibility so I feel the need to say
actually wrote an NPM package that
brings back the blink tag and everything
please don't use it it's a joke please
just don't it's not even like minimized
or anything like it's not production
worthy it's just there to prove point
please don't last thing I need is my
accessibility but he's going what in the
world are you doing to the world so
please don't but that's why we're gonna
use as our example today so essentially
what we're gonna do is we're gonna
create a component and it's gonna blink
and I the code will blink more often
than that I limited the code that
blinking three times not too fast so I
don't make all of you seasick and don't
like you know distract everybody doing
the entire talk because that would be
obnoxious so just know that if you're
actually running the code that's there
it'll keep blinking at nauseam and
forever so what are we going to do
there's two types of custom elements we
can build there's a autonomous custom
element that's what we're going to build
today which allows us to build a custom
element from scratch to do whatever in
the and the world we wanted to do the
other ones is a customize that built-in
element which means you're taking an
Allen HT element that naturally exists
inside the spec already so you're
probably your paragraph tag your div tag
your button pick your poison and you're
doing something to extend its
functionality we're just going to go
ahead and build something from scratch
because obviously blink doesn't exist
anymore it's not like we can go and try
to do more stuff with it because we can
get to it anymore and it won't work in
most modern browsers so we're gonna do
an autonomous custom element and so in
order to do that and all of this is in
es6 in text we're gonna create a class
and which basically extend n HTML
element none specifically just HTML
element and at the very beginning of our
class we have to have that super
otherwise it is not going to work
properly and that will allow us to
create the prototype chain and the
correct order it'll work just fine other
thing is all of the basically everything
related to the code we're going to talk
about from now on it's pretty much other
than that the very very end is in that
constructor everything we're going to do
is going to be in the constructor of the
class and then after that we need to
actually append that and the register it
with our custom element registry and we
do that by using custom elements define
at blink now notice how it's got the app
blink at the bottom and I couldn't just
call it blink all of the custom tags in
order to word have to have a dash in
there because it kind of differentiates
them from more normal HTML elements that
are generally out there so you're gonna
have to put a dash in there somewhere
you can have three or four of them if
you want a super long name for whatever
reason but you have to have at least one
so I got I was boring and just called it
a blink and then we just reference our
actual class of blink from there what
we're going to do is actually get to
that shadow root and so what we're going
to do is go ahead and establish we're
going to attach a shadow
I'm scuse me words we're gonna attach
shadow which allows us to go ahead and
open that shadow DOM and we're going to
use the mode of open there's two modes
open and closed open allows us to use
auto route in the parent to go ahead and
access the the shadow Dom and get some
information about it clothes would
return that as null so if you're
creating the component for maybe that's
going to be used by a client I like in
an outside source and you really don't
want them thinking with it in any way
shape or form you might want it closed
in order to lock it down there's no
reason for us to do that right now so I
just want left it open what we're going
to do would work either way but worth
knowing that those
there's a differentiation between the
two so the first thing we're gonna do is
in our HTML we're just gonna say app
blink so that's what we call their tag
right and I'm gonna add an attribute of
text and then we're going to take that
text put it inside of our component and
go ahead and make that blink so our in
rjs what that looks like is I'm going to
create a wrapper so that I can easily
attach all of my stuff inside of my
component to go in ahead and display
since I'm just displaying text I'm gonna
use a span because it's an inline
component it'll go put itself wherever
it's supposed to and then I'm gonna get
that attribute of text and I'm gonna go
ahead and put it as the content instead
of inside of my span inside of a wrapper
and go ahead and append that all to my
wrapper it's good it's there we're we're
in good shape so now our HTML if we look
at the output instead of our developer
tools just shows a span of hello world
we're good and does a whole lot of
nothing yet because we still need to
make it blink so that's when we get into
the CSS side of things so the next thing
we're gonna do is go ahead and add some
CSS to it so we're gonna go in and out
of the class leaf a class of blink
because you know super original right
we're still dealing with the blink tag
and we're gonna go ahead and define that
style document.createelement style and
inside of that style I'm gonna put some
CSS basically standard a little keyframe
that makes it blink forever and ever
hence the infinite and it's the
animations gonna loop every minute every
second it's gonna go ahead and blink and
I'm gonna pend that style to my element
which now we have a nice little blinky
tag and our output shows hello world and
we can blink and has that class that we
just added however the downside to this
is how many of you actually like having
that CSS right there inside of your
JavaScript yeah me neither so let's go
ahead and pull that out and put it
inside of a CSS file where it belongs
right since we saw seem to agree on that
one let's go ahead and put it where I
can actually like for sure say it like
it's a house so let's go ahead and do
that so we're gonna actually could still
create that style
because we still need to somehow define
that it's going to have a style but
instead of actually injecting all of
that CSS and they're just going to use
CSS import give it the file name that
we're going to put right there with our
and the same folder as our HTML and
JavaScript and there we go and we're
gonna pin that instead of our big chunk
of JavaScript and now our CSS is neatly
tucked away in a CSS file where it
belongs instead of inside of our
JavaScript file now there's a little bit
of a thing with this one once you do and
start bundling it for for it in order to
make it into a package in order to put
it like on the NPM registry those paths
can be a little funky and so you may
need to build some some you may need to
do some build stuff around it in order
to get the because those paths has those
paths will fail as soon as you try to
bundle it so worth noting but in terms
of development it's a pretty easy it's a
pretty easy script to go ahead and fix
those at run time in terms of
development this is a lot easier to
contend with and a lot more maintainable
so we still have the exact same thing we
had before and it's great we have a
blank tag it's awesome but it's just
text we want to blink more than just
text right if we remember the original
blank text we could blink the entire
page if we wanted to right so let's
figure out how to do that so that's
where slots come into play
so I mentioned slots a little bit
earlier what those are gonna allow us to
do is actually take some markup that's
in our parent component shove it into
our blink tag and allow us to blink our
entire page potentially so in order to
do that the first thing we're going to
do is we're going to go ahead and make a
slot so slots are named and that's
because potentially you could have
multiple slots we're only going to have
one but for you think about maybe a card
component where you might have a title a
body and a footer right you may want
multiple slots so that's why they're
going to be named and anywhere in the
code they're always going to be
referenced by their name so in our case
I'm going to just call it blink content
so we the first thing we're gonna do is
we're going to create that slot we're
gonna set the attribute of name blink
contact and appended to our wrapper
append order does matter so when you are
appending stuff to it especially if you
say have a title a body and a footer
like we just talked about for the card
if you do those in the wrong order it'll
if you do the footer first for example
append your footer first and it'll be
the first thing on your list so make
sure when you're keeping track of Europe
ends that you got the order in which you
put them on there is going to matter a
simply and just the the way the display
HTML ordered on their screen unless
you're doing some funky something like a
display absolutely and CSS or something
if you're just following the natural
order of the HTML it's just gonna go in
the order in which you append your stuff
and then in our HTML what we're gonna do
is we're going to create a div inside of
which I'm going to which I'm going to
put that our tribute of slaw that's how
my component is going to know hey this
is the content I need to take and put
inside of my of my blink tag and go
ahead and put my content then and there
I was boring I put a paragraph tag but
you could put the entire page you could
put lists URLs whatever links to pick
your poison unicorns rainbows whatever
fancy do so from there we still accept
Lee have the same thing we had before
the difference is now it's taking that
paragraph tag that we have inside of our
inside of our slaw and putting that in
instead of putting that attribute that
we're using before the really cool thing
about this is this is one of the few
ways that you can actually interact with
what's inside your component because
those we we talked about there being
isolation there right so that's kind of
look at where we can and cannot fiddle
it things so that's our paragraph jug
yay so we're actually gonna style that
paragraph tag the style dot CSS anytime
you see that we're talking about the
application CSS versus anytime you see
blank that CSS that's when we're talking
about the actual components yes that so
it's gonna matter because based on where
you put what that's going to affect
whether only what's in the component
gets affected or what only what's in
your application gets come get Safed and
there's no translation and no crossed
termination between the true they're
completely isolated from themselves I
also use the variable notation because
it makes it easier to play with stuff
for our colors so what I'm gonna say is
in my opt-out CSS
I'm gonna tell it hey I want it to be
underlined and of my primary color which
happens to be a Bluegreen normally if
you would do if you were to do that and
we had used the attribute tag those
Styles wouldn't matter have shown up
because at that point the the it would
have been trying to effect something
inside of the component instead of this
the paragraph is still considered to be
inside the parent because if you
remember that slot is actually being
defined inside of the parent not in our
JavaScript where we created our
component so that's where the really
cool part comes along so anything you
shove in there cannot be styled from the
parent so that allows a lot of
flexibility to say these are things I
want my users to be able to fiddle with
and I want you to be able to show
whatever content you want here or this
one no I really want this to just be a
string only give me a string because I
want it specified a specific way or only
give me X type of concept content
because I'm going to take it and do
whatever with it in order to this light
so that allows some really nice stuff in
there so now let's look at how we can
even take that a step further and out a
button to it because we're not or we're
you know accessibility matters and we
don't want to blink at people constantly
it's cute for about two seconds and then
it gets old right so that's a lot of
people to start and stop the stuff so
what we're gonna do is we're gonna add a
button that allows you to make it start
blinking and make it stop already
because okay the jokes over so first
thing we're gonna do is create a go
ahead and say hey I'm gonna start it on
false because I want people to be able
to play with it but I don't want to
shove it in their face so I'm gonna make
it start on false they can make it start
whenever they want I'm gonna create a
button
so just element doc document that
created on my button I'm gonna give it a
type button obviously and I'm gonna have
an inner text if start blank and so
we're going to be able to toggle that
later in order to make money to make it
change the text for it to stop blinking
and we're going to go ahead and append
all of that to our button because a
whole lot of a pen to all the places
again
upend matters so I want my button to be
be underneath by blinky stuff so I'm
gonna put it at this last thing I pinned
I generally keep my style somewhere at
the bottom somewhere because that one
doesn't really matter when it gets
appended unlike the rest and but if we
wanted it to appear before our blink
content then we would have to put it on
the top right we would have to be the
first thing we do so since our slot is
appended first in our button is appended
second we're gonna have our blink
contact first in our button second so
then we're gonna do a little bit of
blank logic pretty standard JavaScript
there where we're just gonna say hey if
blink is true go ahead and stop it
if blink is false go ahead and start it
and switch the text accordingly so that
users know what's gonna happen with the
button and do it on click so we still
have our nice little button and we can
press it and we can click it and it's
perfectly fine now what happens if I
create a button out so and we styled it
I didn't show the CSS because that's
kind of not the point but we styled it
to kind of match um
the what happens if i take a button
outside of my component and i get it in
a completely different style I want my
buttons in the rest of my application to
be in for the font to be in cursive for
whatever reason completely unreadable
but we'll do it anyway because it's a
nice way to show what happens there is
because that is cells that are that are
in the parent application and that
inside of our component it is only going
to affect things outside of our
component not inside so which means that
me as a developer offering a UI library
say part of the marketing team has told
me I want to make sure that all of our
component looks like X make sure that
nothing gets fiddled with I can say sure
you can do whatever you want in your app
the components that we're providing to
you are always going to look like X no
matter what you do outside of it so
that's kind of cool because now you see
I add the curse of it's only affecting
buttons that are in the application
proper not our component itself
so any kind of styling you would do
would also get affected and as you can
see the styles that are affected on the
button that are inside of our component
do not bleed into our parent application
either there's complete isolation
between the two
there is one way you can affect the
styles
inside of the parent component inside of
that component now that I've said you
can't now I'm going to show you how you
can do it any way the way you can do
that is at the top of that custom
element that shadow host there is a CSS
property that will allow you to affect
that and what that does is the host is
the equivalent of saying your HTML
component you've got your body or you
can set styles on HTML or on body think
of it the host as kind of the same thing
it's kind of the HTML tag or the body
for your component and so what you can
do is not only can you set styles to it
which means that anything inside of that
component will have those styles but it
also means that you can take host
context and go ahead and take that so if
we were to add a class to our custom
component host context allows me to go
in check for said class and if that
class is true then we can go ahead and
apply different styling for example so
if you were to theme something like have
a dark theme and the light theme or have
maybe primary versus accent colors or
whatever the case might be you can go
ahead and have attribute you can go
ahead and add class names to those to
your custom components and have the CSS
inside of that component check does the
does my host have this class and then
change the styling accordingly so in
this case I'm using host context of dark
it's looking for does my does my custom
component have a class of dark in our
HTML went ahead and put a class of dark
so yes it does in which case for the
button I want make sure that I have a
different background color and a
different a different font color and so
that allows me to have two versions for
a button even though we only have one
component because I can style them
differently depending on if Emily and
light beam or dark theme so that is one
of the very few ways that you can
actually affect your CSS inside of the
component have you guys ever seen these
I'll give you a hint don't use them so
deep
deep and deep which are shy or the three
arrows which are short card for deep our
our be still will work in most angular
versions which is where they gets
confusing that's because if you're not
fiddling with it
angular by default is a emulated Shadow
Dom it's not actually using shadow Dom
browsers have deprecated and killed
depending on the browser support for
this so even if it works today and the
particular browser that you're testing
for ID not chrome they won't work in
Chrome
I haven't checked Firefox in a while it
will quit working in the very very near
future it hasn't stopped working today
already these allowed you to say yeah
about that encapsulation nevermind I'm
gonna go and you know change the styles
inside of that component anyway and
that's creating problems because now you
have this entire ecosystem of I have
components they're completely ain't
isolated I provide a component libraries
people can't fiddle with it it'll be
great and developers are like haha yes I
can so those are actually they weren't
implemented for a while in some browsers
but they are being deprecated you will
still see it work in some of the
libraries because they've either
built-in support for it or they're using
emulated emulated encapsulation and
that's why it still works but yeah and
when you're dealing with native
JavaScript components that is a truly
bad idea if it works at all for the most
part it won't work so yeah don't use
those probably shouldn't be using them
in the other components either but and
when you're using a framework either but
that's neither here nor there so what
about IDs we've already established
classes are isolated what about IDs
because ideas can be fun right because
if you first off if you have the same ID
multiple times that's already a bad idea
right because that's not validating HTML
to start with so on top of that you get
some functionality fundis if you have
the same ID and you're on multiple
elements and you're calling it and then
gross happens but this is a component
mean we may want to have seven or eight
of them on the same page right probably
don't want to blink several Rhino things
but you know the use case right but it
might happen so let's go ahead and add
some IDs
things and see what happens in terms of
that interaction so I'm gonna set inside
of the button on my HTML I'm gonna set
an idea of button and I'm also going to
set an idea of button inside of my blink
component so they both have the same ID
right on both sides of the fence so
we're gonna see what happens so both on
the HTML inside of the component and on
the one in our application and on both
cases I'm gonna say hey this is one of
the few times where I'm not inside of
the constructor because I'm saying that
button that's in my application I want
you when you get clicked because our
other one already handles the button or
is already handling our our blink on
blink off right the one in my
application instead of having the blink
on blink off what I want you to do is I
want you to throw a hello world instead
it already doesn't do the blink on blink
off so I guessing you guys already
figured out that it's not going to
translate but for purposes so now we
have a insider of application we're
saying idea button I want you to throw a
hello world alert inside of our
component I want you to go ahead and
start and stop the blink guess which one
is going to throw the hello world
anybody the one in the application the
one the other one will not throw it
because it's completely isolated between
the two so that's a really cool bit so
not only are they completely insulated
from a styling perspective they're also
completely insulated from a
functionality perspective which means
you don't have to worry about having
ideas you can name your things like
classes that make sense and IDs that
make sense without a bunch of extra
numbers and stuff because there's no
problem with repeated IDs because it's
completely insulated it's completely
independent from what's going on outside
of it and again with your classes so any
of you use bootstrap at all at some
point in your career how many of you who
tried to do a class container and then
realize on for CSS and realized that
away bootstrap already hijacked that
name and so now we have to come up with
ridiculous other names when we could
have just been using container right so
those are the things that having that
complete isolation prevents it means
that you can still have completely
similar
techne naming that makes complete sense
inside of your components and inside of
your app and not having to worry about
the interaction between the two and that
all just basically out of the box
without having to do CSS modules or CSS
weird or anything in terms of the build
or anything because it's already right
there canned and out of the box so
that's one of the features that I found
particularly interesting with using
those so packaging it up because it's
all fun and games to have components but
I need to be able to ship it off to
teams right to be able to use and view
react angular or whatever so let's look
at how that works pretty simple I'm
gonna use the pretty a little bit newer
but the whole concept of JavaScript
modules right there in es6 I'm gonna go
ahead and take my my blink tag and I'm
going to go ahead we have I kind of
shortened it for ease of readability but
you've got your class where you've
defined your component we've got our
we've got our element and then we're
just going to export it and so now we
can have access to it create a nice
little module that has I also run ahead
and rinse they did the marquee tag
because if you're gonna do blink you
have to do marquee right I mean it's
kind of sad if it's just blink so you
can go ahead and put those together have
a have your export the advantage of
doing it this way is that because I have
them both independently set up with
exports and then have like kind of a
barrel set up with all of them I can
choose to either import them one by one
in my application or I can just to
import the entire barrel and have access
to all of them so that's kind of cool if
you have a lot of components and you're
worried about like the weight of just
you know so that your users can just
choose hey I really just need this one
component that's a lot more helpful if
they're using the full library being
able to just import the barrel is a lot
easier so it gives a little bit of
flexibility that way so from there just
basically take that take that one tire
file go and basically and NPM ship that
ship that stuff put it up on a repo and
see what happens super simple I can
import it this one is a local import of
the vanilla retro that's that that was
our barrel
I'm just importing blinkin
key it just works I put it in and poof
on my page we have a beautiful blink tag
it just works the one that I have in the
published library is simply the normal
blink it doesn't have all of the button
and the fun stuff in it it's just a
normal blink tag so it just works simple
this is if you were doing just a static
HTML page a little bit of a warning if
you do that if you decide to try to play
the import game you'll get this
beautiful error from chrome that says
cours hates you because cours always
hates everybody
because who likes having course errors
yeah they're fun the way to get around
that is if you're doing an import from a
barrel you need to go ahead and serve it
up on HTTP or HTTPS so I use HTTP server
that's super simple but you need to have
it actually served up if you try to run
it just locally as a normal file you'll
get a pretty pretty core zero and it
will basically give you tell you that no
it won't do it so what about angular
because the point is we've got vanilla
vanilla vanilla vanilla what about
putting it in angular what we can just
do a simple import my J's file that's my
nice little barrel it's got all of my
stuff the thing is that one's been a
throwing error too because all of a
sudden it's not going to recognize that
as a custom component because it's not a
component you built an angular so
angular doesn't know that that component
exists so you're gonna have to be to
tell your application that it's got a
custom element schema um so if you just
tell it that it's gonna ignore the fact
that it doesn't recognize the component
and move ahead you can actually define a
schema if you wanted to like lock it
down to specific component names but if
you just put that up and it'll go ahead
and ignore the fact that it doesn't know
what it is that angular itself doesn't
know what it is and go ahead and give
you a nice little blink tag and so
inside of uh and I actually called my
library retro blank because I try to
call it tried several different names
and they were all taken because yeah I
mean how easy is it to find a name on
NPM that isn't taken yet it took me a
good it took me longer to find a name
than to actually write the library just
say but so it's it's called
trope link once it's packaged and inside
a library on NPM but it totally works in
angular so what about view cuz I mean
can't forget view I also have react
don't worry
same idea we go ahead an import view was
even nicer I didn't have to do anything
with the schemas or anything by doing
the what is it view run I was a it's
already being served up so I didn't have
any errors no problems and it just kind
of worked so what about react can you
guys guess is it gonna work yeah react
same thing did is just normal import
retro blank put my slot and it just
works as well so that is how you go
ahead and make vanilla components that I
mean you could try this with mithril and
all of the libraries Under the Sun I
don't know them all but you get the idea
you import it and you may or may not
have to do a little bit in terms of
making sure whatever framework of it
recognizes that component or not
depending on how picky the composed the
framework is but you can go ahead and
take it import it and it just works so
this is where the the github is where I
have the code the NPM is the actual
package itself if you guys want to pick
that up and the bitly at the bottom is
where you can find this slight deck any
questions cuz that is what I had for you
guys
[Applause]
yes no because the customer tag is
actually the host so if we go let me go
back to where's my mouse yes so if we go
back to this whole diagram the custom
element itself right up here is what
that custom element is so in and of
itself it cannot also be the slot if
that makes sense because that's what
we're in the if you look at the Dom tree
that's where it's being opened
so it might work in some browsers maybe
I'm not sure but I would it's not meant
to because that's where you're shot well
that's what's attaching the root and
it's also going to cause issues in terms
of your CSS and your host context and
stuff it's a pretty bad idea in general
so now you you definitely want that
sacrificial component with us a div or
otherwise because as you may have I
don't know if you know I don't know if I
pointed it out but that whatever that
component you're setting a slot is
really kind of ignored
it's a mmm you could you could
technically put it on the template
component essentially because it's it's
not translating into it at all one other
thing I forgot to mention about that
when one of the few things that does
pierce that that is the LD Aria so if
you have a button inside of a component
your accessibility tree will be able to
read that so that's cool that's worth
knowing but it but if you're trying to
if you have an input field and you're
doing a for to figure out where the
label is and those are in and out then
you won't so make sure you know those
were those intricacies last but no
attaching it to the to the host would be
a bad idea because that's where your
entry point into the shadow does that
make sense
anything else yes
okay you would have to make sure that
you have polyfills for every last a
little bit there are polyfills out there
I have not played with them but my
assumption is that you ran it through
Babel you might be able to get something
working but I have not tried it because
I kind of in this for this particular
context know I didn't need to and so it
was not like but I would assume that
with the correct polyfills ran through
Babel you may have a shot at maybe yes
you
so what he was saying is that there is
actually a web component jobless
polyfill that you can use so that's the
answer anything else yes
well because it's just it's just
JavaScript so at that point anything any
kind of testing framework or a testing
system that you would use for standard
JavaScript you could use to test your
component at that point so because of
the encapsulation you might want to
divvy out your unit testing to make sure
that the quote is organized that your
unit testing can test what's inside of
the component but know it's a it's just
JavaScript so any kind of framework or
testing tool that you would use to test
JavaScript would work yes
yes and that's where you may instead of
like I blink Italy just allowed custom
elements kima but you can't actually
define what schema that it would be
allowed to and not allowed to use it's
somewhere in the documentation buried
and but at that point if you're dealing
this in production I just went well blob
west and let it just accept everything
but you can you would probably want to
define iski it's the same way XML right
you can set XML to define a schema or to
be allowed anything it's kind of the
same idea yeah yes
yeah so they would Bob events would the
question was if would events inside
would invent bubble because of the
encapsulation and the events would
bubble within the encapsulation but not
out so if you had like several layers
and like maybe several you know like
several layers inside of your inside of
the component it would bubble all the
way up to wherever I needed to inside of
that component but not out so it would
stop out the bubbling would stop at
wherever the component stops so there's
no interaction between what's inside and
what's outside yeah so you would have to
have an attribute or a listener or
something to communicate between the two
that's where you'd almost have to have
something very similar to the prop
system and react or an or event
listeners and handlers inside of angular
I haven't really played much with trying
to do it with what the components but
it's obviously like finding no it's
probably possible I would I just haven't
dug that deep I need to cuz you're the
second person who's actually that at
this point yeah well thank you guys